so good to see you look amazing we got
the leather leather we got the memo and
we brought out the leather because
tonight's a big night congratulations on
your honor so well deserved but I know
that you know because you're a girls
girl this is a ton of women we gotta be
there for each other we gotta support
each other who is the woman in Hollywood
who constantly motivates inspires and
uplifts you to constantly arrive at your
best oh my God I'm I'm so blessed and
lucky that I work with so many
incredible talented motivational women I
mean Euphoria is just a kick-ass cast of
females and then I just finished Madame
Webb as well merced's here tonight and I
got to work with Dakota Johnson and
Celeste O'Connor so
honestly all the females that I get to
work with because the fact that they got
to the point that they're at means
they've worked their ass off and I'm so
proud of them for sure and you too I
want to do a really quick rapid fire
Sydney Swinney Sydney Sweeney resume
moment okay first things first
Barbarella we're so excited about this
what are you most excited to give to
this character with your like 2022 lens
I'm really excited to serve all the fits
oh but also just it's it's such an
iconic fun character and I want to keep
that fun alive through Barbarella so I'm
excited for everyone to see it have you
reached out to the Jane Fonda I can't
say okay and we love the picture seeing
you on the set of Madam Webb with Dakota
Johnson what are you most excited for
fans to experience on what really seems
like a girl power set I mean you got
some kick-ass girl superheroes
can you describe it in three words nope
Halloween is coming up you know that
Maddie and Cassie hugely popular
Halloween costumes have you run into any
Maddies or Cassie's while you're out
what do you make of the massive
popularity I have not personally run
into any but I hope I do because that'd
be a lot of fun I think it's amazing
it's just it's so cool Alexa and I love
it it means a lot to us that these
characters have just impacted culture in
such a way so it's a lot of fun
foreign